ben affleck gets caught snoozing on the
scent i i i have no explanation for that
i'm gonna tell you as he and wife
jennifer lopez take their love to perry
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time after tying the knot
in an intimate wedding a little over a
week ago in las vegas the newlyweds
jetted off to the city of lights for a
vacation with their kids now et has
learned that they're not on their
honeymoon it's just a family trip and
all that together time seemingly wore
ben out at one point during a cruise on
the set river with the fam photogs
caught ben catching some z's check out
the actor dozing off with his phone in
hand as he kicks his feet up on the
railing yeah it's probably the jet lag
right ben we do our best hey we can't
blame the guy the lovebirds have been on
the go and exploring paris all while
bringing their fashion a game of course
i always have fun with fashion that's
the pair dressed to the nines on jen's
53rd birthday on sunday matching in
black ben's rocking the suit as she dons
a long gown with a stunning pearl
necklace another accessory that catches
our eye the green balloon in her hand
which we know is a color that holds
special meaning to the singer j-lo
opened up about it while spilling
details on their engagement earlier this
year
and he pulled down a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
and he hands me a ring
and he said it's a green diamond
my favorite color yeah so the green
balloon is fitting for j.lo's outfit on
her special day it's a beautiful moment
speaking of beautiful moments it's been
about a week since bennieford 2.0
surprise vegas nuptials how you feeling
you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
and this
was my
wedding
changing area
the wedding went down at las vegas
little white chapel where a small group
of family and friends watched as the
couple said i do nearly two decades
after they broke off their first
engagement and roughly a year since they
got back together i feel like there's a
lot of life ahead of me so i'm very
excited about it and there's more
celebration ahead for the lovebirds
because the party is just getting
started a source tells e.t ben and jen
are still planning to have a large
celebration soon with family and friends
to celebrate their love in a bigger way
i mean so much when somebody really
thinks about you and loves you and sees
you feeling so lucky it's not often you
get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
i love you
i love you too
[Music]